a lot of real-life events where we need
to combine multiple data sets into a
single one
consider a survey based on child iq
development conducted in a city where
data has to be taken from all the
schools present the concentration of
existing data sets will produce a new
data set as a result
in the next screen we will talk about
concentrating multiple data sets
together
tax combining multiple data sets is as
shown
here
output sas data set is the resultant
data set created using the data
statement
the set statement sets sas data set 1
and sas data set 2 as input data sets to
be combined
so far we have talked about combining
multiple sas data sets to create a new
data set
when two data sets are to be combined
such that one data set gets appended
with the data set of another
and no new data set is created we use
proc
append we will discuss it in the next
screen
proc app statement adds the data from
one data set into another
the syntax for using proc append is as
shown
here sas data set 2 gets appended with
the data of sas data set 1.
it is necessary that both of the data
sets have the same variables
if they have a different set of
variables the force option is used in
the proc append statement
let us consider an example to understand
the pending databases
examples shown the data of data set c
gets appended in data set a
another way to combine data sets is
merge
we will discuss it in the next screen
is the most commonly used data
combination technique
it combines observations as well as
variables from the source data sets to
create a new data set
merging is done based on at least one
common variable in the source data sets
which is also a necessary condition to
execute merge
another necessary condition for merge is
that input data sets must be sorted by
the common variable
merging is done in a data step with
these statements
the merge statement names the input data
sets
the by statement names the common
variable or variables to be used for
matching
this technique is also referred to as
match merge
the method for using merge will be
discussed in the next screen